you're speaking to somebody who lost her
house I had 8 feet of water and I'm
still not back into that house still
working on the final finishing up that
being said there were some things that
needed to be washed away New Orleans was
home to some of the worst schools in the
whole nation before Hurricane Katrina
hit in 2005 after the storm nobody
expected to see the education
Renaissance that's taking place here now
New Orleans Public Education before the
storm was financially bankrupt morally
bankrupt academically bankrupt in
facilities been public school the
teacher wouldn't really take any time
out to help
it was more like fights and drama and
just because it was in the waters around
killing generally they were moving kids
through the school nobody could read
they were graduating kids from high
school without being able to read kids
weren't being up weren't able to pass
the Graduate exit exam suite Katrina
I think this 2003 almost is the epitome
of our massive failure the valedictorian
of one of our high schools could not
pass a graduation exit exam after six
attempts she kept failing math though
her transcript had straight A's in
Algebra one two and trig and you can
pass our graduation exit exam not
knowing algebra as has been demonstrated
time and again traditional public school
systems are ill-equipped to deal with
the challenges of educating for minority
students
before the storm things were so bad in
New Orleans that most people had given
up hope some reformers at the state
level however decided it was time for
change 2003 the state created something
called a recovery school district and it
was designed to address the fact that
some schools were object-- Lelo
achieving schools for very long periods
of time in taking that school away from
the school board you would strip it of
the board policies the board contracts
including the collective bargaining
agreement and out came the school the
children and the money and a fresh start
it was a very small effort and it was
pretty much ignored by the unions at the
time that would of course changed later
when the larger takeover proposed in
August of 2005 Hurricane Katrina hit
a day that the storm was about to hit we
went to school and then he was closed
because he didn't look at the news that
day so he left that same day so Katrina
devastated the entire area nearly 1500
people died more than 1 million were
forced to leave their homes and the
storm caused nearly 100 billion dollars
in damages for the already failing
Orleans Parish School District Katrina
appeared to provide the final death blow
first of all a great number of the
campuses that the schools were flooded
Orleans Parish schools were flooded
damaged beyond repair my understanding
is that they were incredibly
underinsured when you're in New Orleans
in January 2006 there are not school
buses there are not cafeteria workers
there are not homes for teachers there
are very few buildings there are no
books on August 29th you had 126 schools
and the next day you had none and by the
end of that first school year you only
had six schools operating in the city of
New Orleans but when all appeared lost
education reformers began looking for a
silver lining
after the Leddy's broke the city is shut
down and the conversation in Baton Rouge
was really we cannot let the school
board open up these schools again we
have the opportunity for a much broader
fresh start what was really different
about taking over most of schools in the
cities the strategy for takeover would
be that we would charter these schools
if you were a teacher with Orleans
Parish in many cases you lost your job
you didn't even know about on the other
side of that those of us who knew that
there were there was so much broken that
needed to be fixed it was kind of like
saying whew let's wipe the slate clean
let's start over what can we do to make
this better
since the post-katrina take over the
school system in Orleans Parish has been
radically transformed this year
sixty-one percent of our students go to
charter schools we project next year
we'll be 70 percent unlike traditional
public schools charter schools are
autonomous entities that aren't hindered
by collective bargaining agreements or
bureaucratic red tape if you're in a
charter school there's no longer tenure
and the charter schools have total
control of the time people and money I
think that we do have really talented
people on staff that have great ideas
and to be able to implement those right
away just as long as our whole team is
on board a large bureaucracy just means
that progress can happen faster when you
have the autonomy that we have I think
my accountability is to each of these
kids and the parents because when Nia
and I knocked on their doors we promised
them a lot of stuff you find success at
a charter school by producing results if
you are hardworking if you really care
about the children if you put in effort
and you're seeing results and you're
going to be rewarded you're gonna find
success operating as a charter school by
no means guarantees success in fact
according to a recent Stanford study on
average charter schools do no better
than district schools and in a poor city
like New Orleans that is still
recovering from Katrina the challenge is
even more daunting we know that many of
our kids coming from poverty backgrounds
have very chaotic lives when they come
here they know what we expect when they
walk in a line there's a lot of fun at
the school you just have to get used to
a lot of people don't like because they
get in trouble right so I don't know how
it feels to get in trouble too much yeah
it's very straight what I like about is
that the teachers and all the principal
and everybody know D they look at the
students and help them get prepared to
go to college well it's challenging work
because it's a population of kids that
are fabulous but they they have a lot of
means despite immense challenges charter
schools like Success Preparatory Academy
in New Orleans College Prep are
achieving good results New Orleans was
the only City last year able to narrow
the achievement gap on african-american
boys the whole charter movement has seen
scores rise I think I like about here
that they test the key is to make sure
they in the class that they need to be
in everybody who's on a lower level if
they put them in a class together so
they can prosper and get to the next
level so we just started this year 0 1 &
2 our kindergartners came in for the
most part none of them knowing their
letters maybe a few knowing their
letters but generally 80% of them behind
where they needed to be we were going to
flip that statistic we think 80 to 90
percent will be ready for first grade at
the end of the year two-thirds of the
voters do not want the schools returned
back to the Orleans Parish School Board
anytime soon whereas prior to Katrina
traditional public schools enjoyed a
near monopoly on education the current
system is built on choice and
competition whether you're in a
traditional public school or a charter
public school the money follows the
student to the school so what's
happening is you've got a free market
now parents have their choice we have
kids coming to us from all over the city
their kids are not are no longer forced
to go to a poor school in their
neighborhood
the school she was possibly picked on
that was fighting her everything
everything that could have happened to
her was happening to her when she came
here you know the environment is very
peaceful you know so the environment
from there to here is like 200% better
this is a service industry we serving
our kids and their parents and if what
we have to offer is not good enough they
have quality choices all around us it's
still too early to know for sure whether
the New Orleans experiment and school
choice will succeed over the long term
but early results are promising and for
the first time in decades people are
optimistic about the future of the New
Orleans educational system those up
close personal to this reform know that
we are onto something
powerful my main message to each of my
children
as they grow up will be never be
satisfied with mediocrity in a classroom
if your teacher is not teaching let them
know I'm here to learn they said no
matter how poor you are or matter who
you is or when you come from you can go
to college I don't think it takes a
natural disaster but I do think it takes
a radical shift in thinking I believe
within the next couple of years we're
going to outperform the suburban parish
that abuts of New Orleans
and when we do that there'll be a little
mini earthquake it's a very exciting
amazing thing to be a part of really
amazing